THIS IS A BIG MOVE IT SEEMS
LIKE.
WHY DID YOU DO IT?
>> TUCKER, YOU DOCUMENTED THE
DESTRUCTION WE'VE SEEN WITH
SOROS PROSECUTORS AROUND THE
COUNTRY, WHERE THEY BASICALLY
TAKE IT UPON THEMSELVES TO
DETERMINE WHICH LAWS SHOULD BE
FOLLOWED AND WHICH LAWS
SHOULDN'T BE FOLLOWED.
IN FLORIDA'S CONSTITUTION, THE
GOVERNOR, NOT AN INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR STATE
ATTORNEY, WHERE THEY CAN PICK
AND CHOOSE.
SO I ASKED MY STAFF TO REVIEW
ALL-STATE ATTORNEYS IN THE STATE
OF FLORIDA.
I WANTED TO SEE WHO WAS PICKING
AND CHOOSING.
THIS IS THE GUY THAT ALL THE
LINE PROSECUTORS, ALL THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SAID, HE THINKS HE
CAN PICK AND CHOOSE WHICH LAWS.
HE ACTUALLY SIGNED LETTERS
SAYING HE WOULDN'T FORCE LAWS
AGAINST TRANSGENDER SURGERIES
FOR MINORS, LAWS PROTECTING THE
RIGHT-TO-LIFE, AND HE HAS ALL
THESE POLICIES IN HIS AGENCY
THAT ARE CALLED PRESUMPTIVE
NON-PROSECUTION.
NO, THE LAW IS PRESUMIVELY
ENFORCED.
I HAD SHERIFFS THERE, FORMER
POLICE CHIEF IN TAMPA.
THERE'S POLICE OFFICERS HAPPY
THIS WAS DONE.
WE TOOK IT SERIOUSLY.
WE DID A THOROUGH REVIEW.
WE PULLED THE TRIGGER TODAY.
>> Jesse: I MEAN, IT'S SO
OBVIOUSLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
LEGISLATURES MAKE THE LAWS.
JUDGES DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE
CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONSTITUTION.
PROSECUTORS HAVE NO ROLE IN
THAT.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
SELECTIVELY ENFORCE THE LAW.
AM I MISSING SOMETHING?
>> NO, YOU'RE RIGHT.
HERE'S WHAT SOROS IS DOING.
IT'S ACTUALLY SMART ON HIS PART.
THEY CAN'T GET THESE THINGS
ENACTED IN THE LEGISLATURE.
HE'LL GET INVOLVED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARIES, IN A
DEMOCRATIC AREA, FLUSH A MILLION
DOLLARS TO GET THE RADICAL TO
WIN THE PRIMARY.
THEY USUALLY WIN THE GENERAL
BECAUSE OF THE PARTY AFFILIATION
DIFFERENCE IN THE JURISDICTION.
THEN YOU GET THEM IN THERE.
THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THROUGH
NONENFORCEMENT.
IT'S A TOTAL END RUN AROUND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM.
THE RESULTS HAVE BEEN
INSTRUCTIVE AROUND THE COUNTRY,
BUT IT UNDERMINES THE IDEA THAT
OURS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
GOVERNMENT OF LAWS, NOT A
GOVERNMENT OF INDIVIDUAL MEN.
>> Jesse: IT'S A SUBVERSION OF
DEMOCRACY.